[Música]
no tengo nada
a causa de una mano
[Música]
porque una canica para un chico una mica
pan no estoy sola aquí está tu cv yate
con agua en mi cante y managua está ya
casi de manera tan bacán y cae mecánica
y mi cante atacante invita etapa guagua
cuna y mata cancha invita y tapa guagua
con una ganancia teniendo a xavi buscan
y con anda ya nada más de katharine y
fue una engañan a chingar hijo un nicho
un hangar pachamama one causa jónico
silla me purines y más para una anécdota
capitán manda y más para una sillita
parís calmando y más para una moneda más
casca manda manda con ayuda nunca
churruca tucumán semana nunca yo nunca
cosa fuma sin navas no acabamos con una
taxista disparó una etapa llegó mito
cuchara
mito cucharón tucu tucu tucu ya con agua
king una dijo un mapa y con una
pasión y está janis catean pero kaipacha
picana causan you can you can't y para
tu cuenta y tag una mamá con una mica
para local cima el cause atacarán zinc y
está cara bonita cara cuya atacarán
y yo no tengo un miedo
porque de las montañas yo vengo y el
viento me regresa a la cascada con mis
abuelos mamá facha yo te siento mamá
facha me conecto me envuelvo
tenga la mafia andina y jane igual
tape y mi cancha una cosita riksichinka
para tu cuerpo una más si me ha causado
una causa y está
ahí está la magia andina esta es la más
bien dina agradeciendo en locura caimán
kayaks y amanda y porque quienes
construyeron este teatro fueron las
manos runas
para que ustedes se deleiten a cano y yo
también para llevar este mensaje a todos
sus corazones para decirles que aquí
estamos para siempre y acá nos vamos a
sostener desde el maíz desde la semilla
[Música]
poca lluvia y pasas
porque ya hay para cazar a su mando a
bajar para nada nada más ganas muy
humanas jiang azúcar nunca yo ya hay
para cha
[Música]
manatí granaria new yok haya quitado
jung woo kim peek chingar y hun y chu
séptimas caspa y my man a muchas casas y
napas se callaría mancha sescam sin
aguacate
casi ná causa ni manchar iscar si nadal
en digipack cuerpo con a terry complica
chin garing que cause quejó y hay hago
me cae muy un team villa que ya me coman
ya usar una cuna hoy con una peña wii
pica culta y ricky ya así que acá lo que
hay para cha pica tekojojá china
kaipacha picar me vine cuchilla tenían
causa etapa y una ya está
pink ambas ya con agua nieta macarena
como un dique y guaranda huaranga tate
es casi me dan agua casting y yang
con una manda arcas en mi camping hay
tapas manager y nicho nunca hatton ya
que una manda ya no pinta caritas yuca
cascada yuca casa
nunca hay pasar
busca tuya y pacha sara zusman natacha
mana diana díaz marcano humana y aunque
nunca busca lluvia y pachá
[Música]
málaga cámara you can hat yai patch a mi
canal de madrid
rip amy atún en kylie bandana q mi alma
mamá para buscar alguna cancha paypal
camaguán causa en china
paypal came agua buen hincha
[Música]
ubiquémonos donde nos corresponde
descolonice mos los cambiamos los de
nombre sembramos la semilla nativa
comencemos de cero la lengua donde se
materializan los sueños pensamientos
diversas diferentes tanto tiempo les ha
sido indiferente desde hacer tampoco
vivimos bajo un solo pensamiento
dominante nos desconectaron de nuestra
propia madre te recuerdo acá no llegaron
mujeres tanto tiempo tanto tiempo tan
heridos memoria de saqueo del conflicto
poniéndonos a pelear entre nosotros
mismos por fines religiosos económicos
políticos y si somos distintos en el
desequilibrio les damos fuerza y poder
al enemigo
a ti te voltea la historia cambia el
paso activan la memoria está en tus
manos salvar la sabiduría ancestral
heredarlo dejarla morir vivir luchando
resistiendo sin fin mientras son los
pocos disfrutan la costa de ti en otro
país o en donde sea
busca ayuda y pasa
busca de ipads ya sabrá si manda pasa
nada de anglada más ganas muy mala
jiang azúcar busca lluvia y pachá
pensamiento rojo puro desde donde el
corazón del maíz
supongo me encantan y química este es
otro pensamiento estamos en muchas
búsquedas pero no es nomás mirada al
cerro y darse cuenta que aquí hemos
estado siempre proponiendo algo
diferente al mundo para que no se dañe
más como cuidando la semillita sembrando
la semilla está regando la semillita que
también es el símil
que es el despertar de la mar o que
reconocer nuestra energía los hombres y
mujeres
amaro mi cariño que acá ni soñando me
buscan y amaron mi cariño haqqani
símbolo de la fertilidad de la humedad
de nuestro libido sexual úteros que se
quedaron en treguas por ser las brujas
más bellas mágicas damas libres
insurgentes enemigas del sistema por
memoria siempre ponga en oposición la
relación con tu cuerpo sucio secundario
te paralizará no sentirás ningún placer
no vas a reconocerte estás en enemistad
entre tú y la serpiente
[Música]
abrimos caminos diferentes somos la
serpiente y abrimos caminos diferentes
somos la serpiente amaro mi cariño
cantillo y anda me vas cante amaro me
cante y cante y soñando a mi vasca y
amaron mi canto yo canté soñando a mi
paz cancha amaron mi cariño cancha
te han dicho que parirás con dolor que
muchos males viven entero hoy es el
triunfo del desequilibrio del
falocentrismo porque nos han temido y
han eliminado saberes y poderes de
curarte que la ciencia jamás podrá
descifrar te exterminando brujas que
ahuyentaba pestes enteras en la edad
media luego eran quemadas en la hoguera
sido la herramienta la estrategia para
dominarlos de poder ellos se siguen
llenando y nos han hecho odiar nos
podemos evitarlo con amor a armarnos a
cultivar
cánticos en man singh y yaris patentes
para tus espectáculos pasan pipa y obama
rumba tarasca una chispa línea rumbatá
rurashpa que llaman agua en pantalla
la one juris va una macana culpepper y
sutil yucateca usted está echada
y ahí me cante
[Música]
abrimos caminos diferentes
somos la serpiente
abrimos caminos diferentes somos a
perder amaron mi cariño cancha soñando
amibas cancha amaro mi cancha la cancha
y soñando a mí bastante amaro mi cante
yo canté y sumiendo a mí bastante amaron
mi cariño
cantillo
al margen comunidades las de resistencia
es la necesidad de armarse de desearse
como serpientes que palpitan al ritmo de
la rebelión contra el gigante robótico
sistema emergimos las mamás de donde
ocupa cha manda jaua camarín a un chica
y pacha picasso mata casa conchi a mamá
news ama finitud humana warmi pura llama
cage y su amante chuck ama finitud sin
llevar mi cuna de harina cancha
amaro china richard y
amar a mi cante nunca antes un anda mi
bastante amaron mi cante yo canté y
sumiendo a mí bastante amaron mi cante y
un cante y soñando a mí para santi amaro
mi cariño cante
[Música]
ama con un ganchito cuya amaru para
chacón chillar y país
[Aplausos]
inti raymi manda para chamizo buscan se
y manda halla power medicina mía me
siento como la wine así el amante de la
ella porque acabo de llegar del inti
raymi entonces les voy a cantar esta
canción con mucho cariño para ver si
ven que esta es una propuesta muy grande
al mundo nuestra organización el inti
raymi nuestras semillas nuestra madre la
escuela
[Música]
una visita a qatar y richard 20 años más
para richard intensamente una mandar más
chispas a morganti entidad de pago a la
culata y está con una mamá con la suya
si la cancha
para mí la música parís un poco y mi
mamá para mí supone coraje pesca sobre
una crítica se manda no hay magia
una tángana de escape watanwal está en
mi culpa al césped machista han visto
disparar sin dinamitar el pamam alcaraz
back
[Música]
minatta poca huella me ama
me haría muy mal del chico para tratar
de buscar una misma la que causa esta
crisis mucho como una cuna caen tengo
tanta pasión time in you can caus en mis
que me asusta ya busca un macho el
switching da pa se agitan a nada y me
mandó a su malla para caricia o años a
causas a síndica mata javi rusia nunca
ya guarda sin ningún arma gris ya
sentían sisa y más hasta causas a una
manda caney virrey mitad ya que justo
la iluminación de la risa igual
[Música]
la animación de una risa igual
camino hacia el de una risa y wendy's
[Música]
una vez más entrelazando la vida la
muerte recuerda el suelo eterno presente
ofrendando nuestra vida que no muere
somos uno solo reino todos nuestra
máxima expresión vibración sonido
descolonización venimos desde el vientre
del sol hayan con el reflejo de la
memoria viva no te olvides de agradecer
aunque sea una vez porque toda la luz y
el alimento permitió el delicioso
fermento reunidos conectando filtrando
los elementos tejiendo el gran sueño con
otro histórico adentro por medio del
baile transformaremos esta es la fiesta
de los guerreros que aznar mi toda vida
a jack una hi pymar y yucatán y mafia
andina riquísimo ni a jamaica señora ni
ni más ya que quien y miami andina más
viajera más
si buscan imagen igualmente una magia
más de primaria toda la vida busca vista
racing y marina luego de altura sino
amarilla la liberación de una desigual
desigual
si alguna residual de la misma gente
igual
[Música]
yo para echarme ellos puede echarle
gracias muchas gracias de verdad vamos a
terminar con
con el grito de la selva
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aquí estamos ya para suavizar nos
gracias al éxito por las nuevas
propuestas siempre va a estar la mafia
andina que proponiendo los quinchos aquí
no sacan una capa de una comuna tú con
tu hoy tantanakushka admite que con agua
me tocó guiar y enturbiar y sacha con
acampar y urkulu natus son tuco y tanda
en la misma mitad que con agua me tocó y
tú quieres en tu clarín el grito de la
selva el ritmo de los andenes juntos
juntos los cantos la más fría andina
está que arde
soy los ritos de mis padres son los
ritmos de los andes soy la sabiduría de
las hierbas hoy la historia viva las
memorias secretas soy mi sangre está
llena de partículas perfectas
ancestrales guerreras
la sangre rebelde que se derramó en la
tierra lo que yo como de ella tiempos
sagrados de cosecha aguas
[Música]
vamos animando iniciando retornando que
la más vieja te ha llegado traficando
los rituales indicados para hacer de los
sonidos algo sagrado yo no quiero hacer
oda al humano y mucho menos ese que
quiere blanquear nos le canto al nuevo
tiempo de retorno que va a llegar
[Música]
sacha que una capa muy rico con esto es
un poco y tantanakushka mitad que con
agua puesto que arento clarín está hecha
con una capa muy cómoda todos son turco
y tan van a juzgarme de aquí con agua me
tocó y tuviera tuvieren antonio ya y
manta
nin a pirri mauer ninguna mi cancha a
chic paraguay para un chico una amiga en
chicha canal está muy un chico y anda
más que espacios ubican si suman saca
frutos a la china hong chih manda y
jacques viña y igual yaykuna wakaychi tu
culpa chata y hasta si tu cuerpo y úrico
y manda aquí ya mis amigas y nadie ha
dado hoy atacáramos muy lluvia y una
transmisión
saya con una capa de marca para toxo
turco y tan dan a buscar mitad que con
agua me tocó estudiar y estudiar en
sacha con una capa de un comodato son
tuco y canadá busca mitad que con agua
me tocó estudiar into quieren
[Música]
a mí que me ofendí nada de mí sin ella
mecánicas de mí que télam argentina tú
quieres tú quieren tocar y el grito de
la selva el ritmo de los andes con todos
los cantos la más plantilla está que
arde el grito de la selva el ritmo de
los andenes con todos los cantos la
mafia china es la que arde ropa hecha ni
gracias te dé gracias a su paisano